hi i'm macarena garcia and i play
natalie alexander
hey guys my name is patricio ayardo and
i play jerry inc hi
my name is annabelle i play sofia
hi guys my name is andres vaida and i
play pablo hey guys
i'm jankel steven and i play raul hey
guys my name is michael ronda
and my character is javier and we're the
cast of control c
and we're about to take a quiz to find
out if we
would survive
let's do this
[Music]
first thing first how would your friends
describe you
terminated loyal witty mysterious
outgoing shy well for me i choose stop
going
i chose mysterious and i chose
mysteriously
loyal determined righteous loyal pick a
netflix character that you would trust
with your secret it's isabella from
control z
guzman from elite tokyo from la casa de
papel
chema from who killed sarah valeria from
valeria
lydia from cable girls i would choose
tokyo i think i'm gonna go for guzman
yeah i went for focus man i picked
lydia from cable girls i chose isabella
from la casa yeah
coolest choose a hacker raul from
control z
rio from la casa de papel garcia from
criminal mind elliot
from mr robot nine ball from oceans
eight
and this bed from the girl with the
dragon tattoo i went for raul
raul i chose elliot from yeah
i'm between elliot and raul but ralph's
my friend so i'm going to go for a
whoa i was not my friend elliot from mr
robert
is he's just i don't know i chose raul
obviously which social media app can you
not live without
instagram twitter facebook tick tock
snapchat
whatsapp i'll go for whatsapp instagram
that one for you
oh what's up yeah what's up i don't even
answer whatsapp so
no it goes you don't i know someone
is threatening to expose your secrets
on social media what do you do call the
police brief them to keep your secret
try to figure out their identity before
they expose your secret tell them
other people's secret in exchange for
keeping your secret
tell everyone your secret before they
can ignore it
you have no secrets i'm really sure i
don't have any secrets
this one's hard i mean i know sofia
would try to figure it out who is it
before
the secrets go out but i would just tell
my secret yeah i would tell my teacher
too to be honest i have no secrets so
last one that's what you say i'm with
michael
last but not least pick a control c
character whose secret
you would keep from getting exposed
sophia secret about her that
javier's secret about his friend
guillermo
maria secret about her pregnancy very
secret about his sexuality
alex secret about her relationship or
natalya's secret about her stealing
i would go for jerry's to be honest not
because i play it but because like
i think you have to get out of the
closet whenever you're ready so i would
go for jerry yeah me too no i would
protect sofia because i would protect
her with my life
i i choose the javier because i think he
changed
after that i mean he's not a bad person
anymore so i think
i would protect sofia secret because i
think
the one that got the most damage out of
it you can see in season two
she really got consequences someone who
actually understands me thank you so
much dude i lost my
my my my family you know yeah so do i
not because of your secret you did
something worse than that
yeah javier michael i love you thank you
for vouching for me
so i survived i survived too mine says
you survived the social media scandal
mine says oh oh you're the hacker you've
been exposing everyone's secret but i'm
sure you had your reasons
you too and the private scandal and i
we're the
hackers were like the coolest people
here no you guys actually didn't survive
ah hey guys make sure to tune into ctrl
z
second season which is now netflix
you